so does that mean if someone went to
let's say live scan like they were a
teacher or notary
their fingerprints would still be in
this database absolutely okay i'm in
there many times right many many many
many times and so if whoever this person
was that was at that step they would be
able to access sort of this big brother
of fingerprints well you have to be in
law enforcement too nice to get into
code uh
sorry automated forensic
indexing
forget the yes
so but it's it's run by the uh from the
fbi
so what if somebody did a diy
fingerprints with scotch tape does that
work i have you ever okay so that's oh
god yeah please my kids do it
i go here go like this and they're like
because that's getting the the i always
say when when doing a needing a print
run your your hair your fingers through
your hair because then you get the
protein and the sweat and all that stuff
on there and then stick it you get a
much better print it develops better for
you if if you will and the and the glue
acts as a
what's the word i'm looking for um acts
as a developer um so they the the not
the glue but the uh the the stickiness
of the tape would actually
adhesive that's the word i'm looking for
would act as a developer so if you do
this the sticky thing you're going to
find a really good print but getting
that dusted and and into
a database
many many many many many steps
so what what would a macgyver of
fingerprints
do let's what are some some diy tips if
we were going to show that in a script
or an actor who's going to play that
besides the scotch tape what are some
other little homemade things they can do
super glue fuming
they did it in beverly hills cop two for
those of you who that remember that
um
where
generally you have a tank because you
need the fumes a supergroup fuming you
have a heating element um i use a coffee
mug
soup heater um and i put stuff into a
little metal
what would i call it a cupcake holder uh
try to get aluminum if you can
smart vinyl
drop
pour a few drops in
place your
suspect
evidence close to it turn on the heater
cover it it could be a terrarium it
could be i i'm just using a plastic box
at home um it was a you know 396 at
walmart it's no big deal about yay big
just so it is a chamber if you will
turn the heat on and then let the fumes
do their thing takes five ten minutes
unlike in the movies where it takes 30
seconds
but the process will
the the super glue for whatever reason
adheres to the proteins
in the fingerprint
and you can do it on a coca-cola bottle
on
on on tin cans and pretty much anything
that's uh non-porous i say non-porous
because if it has holes in it you're
going to have gaps
in your in your in your prints so that's
one one thing and that's the biggest one
is super goofy i do that in my in my
workshops
let's see what else would i have
footprints you can you can develop
footprints
we have
in forensics we have knowns and unknowns
and then and we can compare those things
we're always looking for patterns that's
what we do in forensics everything is
patterns does this pattern match this
pattern does this fingerprint match this
fingerprint that i have on paper
if it does you've got a match and you
can go okay this is john doe
for you know we'll form in the rogues
gallery find out where he is locate them
all you know book em danno all that fun
stuff
um
but with the the footprints you we can
look at the wear and tear on the shoes
are did they walk on their soul do they
walk on their arch that doesn't help you
with your
with with finding the person but it sure
helps with a victimology or with a
profile a criminal profiling
particularly for novels and things like
that oh you know he had a limp and stuff
like that that bushy-haired man with the
limp from the fugitive
but you can actually compare
you can tell this is nike this is adidas
because they have very distinct treads
on the bottom of the shoes
so that's something you can do at home
just take it if you want grab a
an ink blotter and just go
on the shoe and put it on linoleum or
even a piece of paper um it's it's
enough to get the idea of how you can
play with this and this is something i
would even tell actors that we had
mentioned in a previous segment i would
tell actors play with this stuff
it this is how you do how you learn how
you understand things rather than
just going okay i read a script and they
say do this do this this is how you
truly understand and take it to heart
so going back to that theoretical you
know set with the
young police officer actor
they won't be the ones actually
collecting the prince they would secure
the crime scene they would wait
and then they would wait for this
criminologist to come criminalist
criminalist criminologist would be
somebody who studies crime
so criminalists would come and they
would do the dusting and they would okay
great they would not the police officer
would not do it themselves well as you
set it up as a first responder yes their
job is to maintain integrity of the
scene
the emmy would take care of the body and
the criminalists would take care of the
rest of it criminalists aren't even
allowed to touch the enemy and get
fingerprints i mean allowed to touch the
body
um
they have to wait for the me before they
can print uh get prince off of the the
of the decedent as well
emmy has
massive reign they have their own
investigative squads too the uh the
amy's office
if you read uh patricia cornwell novels
she talks very much about having a team
and going out and doing stuff like that
you